the ceo of my pillow mike lindell has
announced that his bank accounts are
being shut down this is crazy deep
banking banning someone from my finance
from a financial institution
it's not the first time it's happened
but boy i would say that's an escalation
in our cultural crisis because if you're
not securing your finances well it's one
of the things that precipitates societal
breakdown people feeling like there's no
path forward there's no safety and
security and what's next people are
going to just take all their cash out
put on their mattress or something
pillows underneath their underneath
their pillows
there you go how's it going
we got some other news too directv is
booting off oan and man
the political divide is getting spicy
because banning people is not changing
things getter is is growing i've got um
you know getter added a new follower
account thanks people complaining about
it i've got like 200 something thousand
followers on getter and i barely use it
but it's just showing that parallel
economies parallel cultures are are
growing and what's next
mike lindell going to launch his own
bank called my bank
i wouldn't be surprised to be honest
because we're already seeing right wing
financial institutions start to pop up
so we're going to talk about all this
stuff joining us today we also have
another major news the biden
administration has officially terminated
darren beatty from uh the administration
can you tell us about what happened to
conserve indeed well i had the privilege
of
serving mr joe biden's administration
the capacity of being on the committee
for the preservation of american
heritage abroad it's a uh
non-partisan committee and one of the
least partisan communities there could
be
and i managed to survive for almost a
year and then just coincidentally right
after
my reporting at revolver.news got
tremendous amount of attention from
trump and from others
um i get a letter from the biden white
house saying
send us your letter of resignation or
get fired by the close of business so
silly as a side it naturally is true you
were you had this job yeah you reported
you had a major story on ray apps and
what's going on with that we'll
definitely get into yeah and then all of
a sudden they pop and say you know what
you're out right now so the timing is
suspicious i say you know this is better
than a pulitzer right
it's a sign that we're pissing them off
and you know i don't blame them for
being pissed off so you know i'll take
it do you want to just briefly introduce
yourself yeah my name is uh darren j
beatty i'm currently a founder
and editor of revolver.news which is a
new site people should check out and in
the past i was a speechwriter and policy
aide for donald trump in the white house
and before that i was a professor of
political science at duke university wow
well thanks for coming man it's the
second time we paid you all right now
it's great to be back it's gonna be it's
hard to beat the last one but we'll give
it a try yeah for those that don't know
uh that was the biggest show we've done
yes it's i think it's got a collective
like if you combine all the views on
everything probably close to three
million views and we put it on rumble
and it's got 2.3 million views or
whatever sorry to interrupt um i'm
hearing that the audio is really
scratchy right now
the audio is great and i just got some
notifications that people are having a
problem
yeah
uh do you want to try turning the audio
on and off i can turn it off it's going
to be interrupting yeah
that may sound better let's see what
happens how's that everybody
give us a uh a one in chat if it sounds
good a two in chat if you're still
having problems let's bring andy in
let's see what it's friday i'm not
complaining you know it's these things
here comes the cto to fix things for us
what do you think oh it's fixed looks
good hey your mirror presence fixed it
look at that
nice oh that's weird how about we just
we we we we do a very brief and quick
start uh restart so welcome to the show
everybody big news on mike lindell
getting his bank accounts shut down
darren beatty is here you're the uh
you're the founder and editor of
revolver news yes
you want to just quickly introduce yes
briefly founder uh founder and editor of
revolver.news before that i was a
speechwriter and policy aid for donald
trump in the white house and before that
i was a professor of political science
at duke university
yeah we got luke hey guys um if you like
giving unsolicited history lessons to
random people like i do maybe the shirt
i'm wearing would be perfect for you as
of course it says fyi the government is
way deadlier than any virus a very true
accurate historical fact especially if
you know what democide means and if you
like to support this historical fact to
the wider general public you can on the
best political shirts.com because you do
i'm here thanks for having me this
should be a great conversation i also
heard that uh compound interest is more
dangerous than standing armies um i
believe that thomas jefferson pointed
that out so we'll keep that in mind as
we talk about banking and mike lindell
may be starting his own did you
introduce yourself i'm ian cross that's
who that is yeah you know me you love me
what's up everybody hey check it out ian
crossland.net if you want to see some of
my stuff and uh we'll talk to you soon
very cool yeah thank you guys for
sending me straight on the audio i could
not hear the difference and i was afraid
to restart while everybody else was
talking so i'm glad we had a chance to
do that hopefully we have some good
sound i'm sarah patch lids i push the
buttons in the corner all right
everybody before we get started make
sure you check out our awesome sponsor
biotrust go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com to get your keto
elevate c8 mct oil powder this stuff
gives you energy it is medium chain
triglyceride oils you mix it into your
drink in fact ian mixed them into his
coffee right down 98 of it already it's
so good it's good stuff i like to put in
my coffee because it's basically a
creamer and if you're looking to eat
healthier lose weight or if you're doing
the keto diet you should definitely
check this stuff out go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you'll get 51
off today and i will tell you this from
personal experience over the past i
don't know how many months have been
five or six months maybe like five
months i cut out sugar and i've actually
lost like i've lost around 20 pounds
that's great someone said that in the
vlog i saw a comment they're like tim's
lost a lot of work that's true because i
wasn't really paying attention or caring
about it but i got i got to be real like
it was partly this because i'm like i'm
sitting here talking about how i use it
and i'm like but i'm still eating sugar
i should actually just do the full on
keto yeah and then i just went you know
full full into it and said all right all
the sugars out and so i've been doing
maybe like 20 grams of sugar per day
very very few uh so again go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com you get a 60 day
money back guarantee free shipping on
every order and for every order today
biotrust donates a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date they have provided over 5 million
meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year you will get free vip
live health and fitness coaching from
biotrust team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
and their free e-report the top 14
ketogenic foods with every order and if
you watch the vlog and you'll see it i
did lose a lot of weight so if you're
interested in that too go to
eatrightandfeelwell.com because i
certainly do don't forget go to
timcast.com become a member because that
directly supports our work we're going
to be hiring another journalist very
soon and we're going to be we're going
to be covering more of like gun rights
and gun culture stuff too as we expand
we've got some ideas for new shows that
are coming and it's all thanks to you as
members we got a new episode of the
green room up with the ceo of rumble and
a massive library of exclusive members
only podcasts we've got mike rowe in
this past week we've got marjory taylor
green you don't want to miss it so sign
up at timcast.com let's talk about this
big news we've got from the
post-millennial
minnesota bank and trust moves to cancel
my pillow founders bank accounts the
accounts in question are lindell
management lindell outreach linda
recovery network lindell tv lindelof
foundation lindell publishing frank
speech michael lindell personal and my
store it's kind of crazy they've gone
after everything associated with this
guy the announcement came on on friday's
episode of war room where host and
former trump advisor steve ben played a
recording of a telephone call between a
top executive at minnesota bank and
trust and lindell's controller
the executive stated during the call
that the bank a subsidiary of heartland
financial had concerns about being
connected with someone who could be in
the news quote
not that the fbi is even sniffing and
looking
but what if somebody came and said do
you know what we are going to subpoena
all of his account records and this and
that and then all of a sudden we make
the news so it's more of a reputation
risk
i'll just tell you this
minnesota bank and trust i would never
go anywhere near
if they if you're running a business and
your bank gets shut down because they're
scared of bad pr
do not bank with these people
it's not just that you think it's just
as mike lindell's a big famous guy
cnn's gone after regular people over
memes
so yeah if a bank is saying we don't
want to be involved with someone in the
news well we know these media companies
are willing to go after regular people
and little old ladies i would not feel
safe banking with that company i i don't
believe the reputation excuse at all
especially when you when you look at the
history of big banks especially
institutions like hsbc and their money
laundering for drug cartels knowingly
doing so when you look at what they did
with jeffrey epstein especially deutsche
bank that literally had to settle a fine
of over 150 million dollars because they
ignored all of his red flags jeffrey
epstein was able to bank with jp morgan
and chase citibank deutsche bank
he never got de-banked who gets debanked
uh the mypillow guy and then people like
julian assange that was debanked in 2010
politically
when he was shut down by a swiss bank he
was shut down by paypal he of course
then went into bitcoin and then had a 50
000 increase of his money and is
estimated to have around 37 million
dollars because of that switch from
bitcoin so again this political
debanking is nothing new the big banks
are of course tied into big government
the intelligence agencies and i think
this is another lesson showing that yes
they all work together
in many extensive ways which is
absolutely troubling because it's
becoming more and more political by the
day i think this is a big red flag for
centralized banking in general you see
the amount of control that i think is
desired from this like the if you want
to if you want to buck the system and
and all the money is controlled by one
person then then you don't get to have
any money anymore and live in this world
with no money that's not how this world
works i don't i don't like privatized
banking at all at this point public
banking yeah i would have a couple thing
to say about that one is the astonishing
and really uh unfortunate thing is there
is a certain case to the reputational
argument which is to say that in the
present regime
you're worse off reputationally being
michael lindell and associating yourself
with donald trump in various ways than
being somebody like jeffrey epstein
they're just
as a result of the peculiar
hierarchy of taboos that exists in the
regime and secondly i think it really
speaks his point that anyone in
liddell's position who speaks out
against the regime in various ways
de-banking is what the united states
government does to adversary governments
it is the domestic
recapitulation of economic sanctions and
so it needs to be understood i think
broadly in this context of the
government and its associated
institutions wielding its power
domestically against american citizens
for political purposes do you think that
the government told this bank to do this
or was this just a private bank well i
mean i think that this this is all part
of the same ecology so the fact that
banking institutions that major
platforms of the communication
infrastructure aren't technically part
of the government they are part of the
regime and um that's what's more
relevant and it's simply if you reach
the level of michael lindell if you are
a dissident on that level you jeopardize
your capacity to exist in any normal way
and having financial freedom and being
able to bank is part of that and so
basically lindell's position is similar
to the position of say the government of
iran for instance that i mean that's how
i would interpret it and functionally
it's the same it's just
in lindell's case he's an american
citizen and in iran's case it is a
foreign adversary or at least allegedly
enough yeah the the public banking thing
i don't know if i'm a fan of yeah after
i said it i was like
not only public i do like the options
non uh like nonprofit banking um credit
unions non-profit banking imagine a bank
that wasn't trying to profit well that's
basically a credit union yeah thank you
so they so for me my credit union it's
like no atm fees i get international
free atm transactions which is crazy
because when i was traveling around for
advice and stuff that was amazing it was
amazing
and uh the the credit union industry was
able to they're able to absorb a lot of
losses because they're not in it for a
profit so during all the occupy stuff
they gained billions of dollars people
were switching over i think that's one
big move you can make but there's still
the problem of a credit union still
being a private institution who can ban
you and so i think what we're seeing
from here is the is the power of
cultural enforcement over uh say legal
enforcement
you don't need to make something illegal
you don't need to violate someone's
rights to still violate their rights you
know what i mean like joe biden doesn't
need to go to this bank and say get rid
of this guy he's in my way they need
only put enough pressure they need a
reporter will call them up and say why
are you doing this i i broke this story
it was a few years ago i think it was
actually four years ago
the uh it was enrique tario he got
banned from chase because a quote
unquote journalist
sent an email basically threatening the
bank saying why are you providing
financial services to white supremacists
and the bank internally just said
terminate we don't have anything to do
with this
i understand why the bank freaks out
journalists do this stuff as an attack
and they know they're doing it the way
they ask the question right for what
business for what public good do we need
to understand why a bank provides
banking services to a person of a
certain political persuasion we don't
everybody has a bank because people have
banks so a journalist who contacts a
bank and asks those questions knows what
they're doing and why they're doing it
that's interesting the way you said
everybody has a bank and uses a bank
because that's kind of what we believe
what we're brainwashed to believe
growing up but like you're saying darren
the government can just sanction anybody
at any time anything and that's a common
tool that it uses in the war against its
adversaries is shut off the bank it's
their favorite tool if you look at the
way that the americans have been kind of
pushing their will on the world economic
sanctions economic warfare are their
main ways of of achieving a lot of their
objectives they go to a country and they
say hey we're going to take away your
ability to even have money in the world
if you don't implement this policy and
this is what the united states does this
is nothing even compared to the world
bank and the imf and if you look at what
uh you know the the stories of the
economic hitman if you look at what
really happens behind the scenes with a
lot of these banks and powerful people
all around the world it is absolutely
corrupt and sinister to see the
corruption that really is happening that
we don't even know about right it's the
analog so what happens to lindell and
there are various other cases he's not
uh he's not the first as you point out
um it is the analog to
you know
using the leverage of the swift system
to cut out you know uh
foreign adversaries or to use that
leverage to pressure them to do
something we want it's it's an extension
of the same basic principle and done for
for the same reasons do you have any
information on the swift banking system
maybe an a brief overview i know a
little bit about it i believe that it
kind of oversees visa and mastercard
right it's i mean it's just you know the
united states government essentially
controls it it's essential for any kind
of transactions that go through
particularly in in dollars and
um it's a major part of being able to
participate in the global economy and uh
particularly in the past five years or
so
um the united states has really leaned
on economic sanctions because there's no
appetite for war since iraq there's just
no public appetite for war and so it's
sort of the middle ground that they can
use to really be severe but not send
troops into a place and so they've
leaned on these sanctions and the cost
is it really puts pressure on the u.s
dollar there's only so much
pressure the dollar can take having to
sustain the united states foreign policy
objectives before
before it the pillars collapse but
they've been leaning on it very hard and
the result is russia and china have been
talking and you know cooperating and
thinking about developing alternatives
to swift system and so forth so
ultimately it might be counterproductive
but
we love to sanction people economically
overseas and that's what you see more
domestically because the domestic
political adversaries like michael and
dell are considered enemies in just the
same way that the u.s government
considers iran an enemy i remember
man 12
13 maybe even maybe it was even like 14
years ago you know alex jones is talking
about
one
one world currency global currency there
all these people on the internet were
talking about the amero that there's
going to be a canadian mexican and
american currency and that always
confused me because i was like can't you
just use your credit card any country
you go to and so within only a few years
i'm traveling around the world working
for vice and i've got a i got a visa
card and i go to all these countries and
swipe it with no questions asked i walk
in i'd say you know let me get the the
the schnitzel when i'm in you know
israel whatever and then swipe
no questions asked no problem just right
there and then i started telling my
friends when i'd hear people say like
yeah one of these days they're gonna
have a one world currency and i was like
bro it's called visa and mastercard you
can go to any one of these countries
just use it right it's here it's
happened already
wait till you learn about bitcoin tim
and i've been telling people bitcoin is
the perfect global store of value
decentralized instant trackable
and when they've got ai
that is tracking all of the transactions
they know who you are where you are what
you're doing and you don't even realize
people are like i can use bitcoin to buy
things you're not supposed to buy it's
like dude they know who you are that's
if you let people know your address so
if no one knows your address
still well there's different ways of
finding out amazon and jeff bezos are
working on a lot of different
technological advancements that would
kind of break bitcoin and that and and
make sure they could track trace and
database everything so there are
exceptions to the world i would say at
this point bitcoin itself
is is is broken in that capacity it's
not private a lot of you know and caps
libertarians thought it really was but
they don't need to know your address to
see the transactions made and then have
an ai just calculate it was you based on
the things you post on social media
based on the phone you use your mac
address they can easily track this stuff
they're working on that technology i
haven't heard of them developing it or
using it yet to be honest let's be real
are they going to publicly disclose they
can do it already
no but it's not that hard to calculate
if facebook is already if you're getting
so i'll tell you something funny i
ordered these little cards they're
really really cool it's a it's a black
card you it's got a joint in the middle
and on the sides and you flip it and it
forms this like kite shape and then you
can pull the sides up and it's got two
little holes where you can put your
phone and use it as a tripod it's so
awesome it like flips around you can
manipulate it and you can take your
phone set it up so you can you know
record yourself with your phone or
record people with your phone the funny
thing is i posted a video to my
instagram of me playing my guitar and i
was trying to set my phone up and i'm
like it's so annoying like how to get
your phone to stand up and then within
an hour i didn't i never said anything
to anybody about this i didn't go gee i
sure need a tripod or some kind of stand
for my phone i get an advertisement on
instagram being like buy this to set
your phone up and i was like that's
really weird it's and it's not because
they're reading your mind or listening
to you i never said any words about this
it's because there are algorithms that
just know based on your behaviors
there's the famous story of the the guy
there's this father he gets
maternity advertisements in the mail for
his daughter and he's like why are they
sending my daughter maternity stuff so
he complains and they were like oh sir
it's because her computer identified
your daughter's pregnant that's it and
she was like how the things she was
looking at and it wasn't this is the
crazy thing she wasn't looking up
diapers she wasn't looking up anything
she didn't know she was pregnant the
algorithm knew that when women start
looking up certain items certain foods
before they even realize that the
computers know they're pregnant and sent
the information to her dad because she
still lived with them that's so i'm
telling you man with bitcoin if you
think they don't know who you are and
what you're doing you are wrong oh it's
all public but but there's zcash there's
monero there are those are a lot better
they get banned they have been in the
past been getting banned from um trading
networks unfortunately yep monero in
particular and that's the thing is once
you reached a level like monero and
you're actually a threat it becomes a
national security issue and so they try
in the periphery they'll ban it from all
the major exchanges it's particularly
hard to get if you're in the u.s
um
and then if it persists then it becomes
you know a a mechanism for terrorism
financing and they'll go after it more
aggressively or they'll just say
so that's the that's the ultimate
bottleneck is once something becomes a
national security threat
um all bets are off well let's let's
talk about national security so you guys
so the big story that came out the other
day was about the oath keepers being
charged with seditious conspiracy yes
something that's really interesting in
this whole january 6th debacle is a man
named ray epps and yeah you guys at
revolver covered this to a great extent
yes we saw uh tucker carlson talked
about it and you have an article up for
those that aren't familiar ray apps is
this guy who's seen in multiple videos
telling people to storm the capital yes
and the funny thing is it is actually
the right wondering why he's not being
arrested and charged so we have this
article from revolver dot news meet ray
epps part two damning new details emerge
exposing massive web of unindicted
operators at the heart of january 6. and
in this one video i'm gonna i'm trying
to lower the volume a little bit i want
to play this just real quick for you
guys
this is on january 5th by the way let me
see i think the audience an audio yeah
yeah the audio is not coming through the
tv
that's my my mistake it was coming
through just very very poorly now it
should be better this is ray epps right
here tomorrow
we need to go into the capitol
into the capitol
[Applause]
right so there's questions around this
guy notably that he was actually outside
the capitol as well right yes and he was
saying something to somebody he was seen
in videos saying this and for some
reason
it's not just that they haven't indicted
him it's that adam kinzinger on the
january 6 committee actually publicly
defended him right who is this guy
what is going on with this that's a
great question and the the video
itself really tells the story and so for
any of your listeners your audience and
i know you have an audience of you know
the full political spectrum i encourage
everyone if you're curious about what
really happened on january 6 take my
challenge go to revolver.news read this
piece in particular watch the video
and then look at me with straight face
look at me in the eye and tell me that
there's not something fishy here i don't
think anybody can in good faith uh meet
that challenge and so who is ray epps
well ray epps is the person we heard
raps is in the mountains of documentary
video evidence of january 6 he's the
only person repeatedly calling and
explicitly calling for this mission to
go into the capital the video that we
saw was on january 5th and he's going to
all different types of groups with
different agendas saying we need to go
into the capital the capital's our enemy
the capital is what we need to do and
then he's not just some drunk guy who's
just spouting off and you you never hear
from him again he's there on january 6
he's a veritable where's waldo figure
he's there telling the crowds after the
trump rally go to the capitol where our
problems are
and then at 12 53 p.m by the way this is
as trump was still speaking so this guy
ray epps who's such a big trump fan he's
wearing his trump hat he flies all the
way to dc from arizona and skips the
actual trump rally in order to hang out
at the capitol
and to orchestrate evidently the first
and decisive breach of the capital
barricades which is interesting given
what he was saying on january 5th and so
there he is on the right by the capital
barricades 12 53 p.m he whispers into
someone's ear that person is called ryan
sam
two seconds later sam cell engages in
the first breach
pretty amazing and in fact there's uh
other video of ray epps telling another
individual who also incidentally is is
not charged with anything he said
when we go in leave this here when we go
in
leave this here and this in this case
was a bear spray so he's already
anticipating
people going into the capital and
fulfilling this mission that he was
calling for the night before and so the
amazing thing about apps is
in the midst of all of these random
grandmas and random people who are being
slammed with the most draconian
charges imaginable for basically nothing
many people wallowing away in solitary
confinement indefinitely
this guy reaps is untouched he's
uncharged
he's unsearched
nobody wants him and until rayapps
essentially became a household name on
the basis of our reporting
um
you know there was zero interest now
now we're told okay shut up about epps
epps spoke to the january 6 committee he
says he's not a fed so go go back to
what you were doing maybe he's not a fed
i don't know or care i can tell you this
what whatever it is the story of ray
epps whoever he is maybe he's not of
criminal informant maybe he's not a fed
maybe he's just some guy he has
completely discredited the entire
january 6 committee narrative for one
reason
adam kinzinger who's on the committee
who's retiring from congress by the way
said
in on twitter on january 11th that apps
was on video the day before saying quote
we're going into the capitol
yet he goes on to say that he never went
in the capital and therefore you know he
cooperated and his name was taken off
the most wanted list okay
their claim is that donald trump incited
an insurrection but donald trump never
even went that far they're claiming that
donald trump said we got to be strong
and we're going to fight that was enough
right if it's not in any way an
infraction or criminal activity to tell
people
overtly on more than one occasion to
enter the capital then what is their
claim against donald trump in this room
right and the negligence with respect to
epps does not exist in a vacuum the most
compelling thing about this that really
points to some explanation like he was a
fed is the selective non-prosecution to
compare the neglect of epps in relation
to the severe charges against
much more minor people for far less
egregious offenses in relation to
january 6. so it doesn't make any for
instance ray up says to one individual
who said when we go in leave this here
well there's another individual called
george tanios who was originally charged
with basically
conspiracy to uh
uh murder
a an officer on the basis of when his
friend was asking
let me have the bear spray he said no no
not yet on the basis of saying no no not
yet they charged him with serious
charges and yet epps is saying when we
go in leave this here and nothing
clearly showing he he had he had planned
right the entrance right following
through with the fact that the last
night he was saying go into the capitol
and leading and he's whispering in the
guy's ear two seconds before the initial
breach and they don't want him and
another interesting detail in that's in
the revolver piece is that initially the
fbi put him on their most wanted list he
was originally so important to them that
he was one of the 20 people considered
you know egregious enough that okay
we're going to put him on the most
wanted list they begged the public they
said help us identify this man reps the
internet being the amazing sort of crowd
source investigative vehicle that it is
identified this guy within days and the
government had no interest and the only
time they took action on epps was the
day after revolver news published an
extensive report on his fellow oath
keeper stuart rhodes the day after an
absolute oath keeper he was a president
he was a president of the arizona
chapter of the oath keepers and so the
day after revolver hold on sorry sorry
uh when did he leave the oath keepers
that i don't know because i i
put a pit in your thought don't lose
your track i just want to say the oath
keepers 11 of them are being charged
with seditious conspiracy yes here you
have a guy who was in the oath keepers
overtly saying down to the capitol and
he's not he it's not just that they're
not charging him i don't know why any of
that's going on it's that adam kinzinger
is actively downplaying what he did and
i i don't know why
right i mean there's no if there's an
innocent explanation for the epps issue
in particular because he was originally
on the fbi's most wanted list and they
quietly took him off and didn't want to
hear from him again and in fact the only
additional remark they had on him before
this blew up on a national scale was
phoenix fbi agents
denying knowledge that he even exists
which is remarkable because he's from
arizona is it confirmed that his name is
rey apps yes
so maybe another organization hired this
guy to go ruffle some feathers the fbi
didn't know so they put him on the most
wanted when they pulled him in they the
other agency came was like hey this is
our guy that's that that is a very
plausible scenario it's entirely
possible that um he's giving them
everything they wanted you know at first
they were like who is this guy find him
and then he gave them something
substantive right i wonder what he would
have given them because you know he was
the most egregious player there so
who would he be giving up that's you
know that's the question i would have if
he's
you know from the video
well maybe he had oath keeper
communications
and they said he can provide encrypted
communications and access to their whole
network because he was a president
but he wants immunity and they said deal
the problem is
look that you know adam kinzinger comes
out he's like this is a conspiracy
theory not only is he not an agent he's
not even an informant and he never went
in the building and i say to all that
adam you are correct
you are also correct when you say that
by yelling at people to go into the
building he did not incite an erection
in an erection
we laugh and it's funny um uh not only
so so the point is it's not a crime so
now they can hope they can drop all the
trump stuff and they can now marjorie
taylor green madison cawthorne all of
these these republicans who they're
accusing of incitement nope sorry you by
by by kenzinger's own words that's all
done with
and you make fun of me for messing up
anyway
this is a this is an interesting
situation because it does you know
suggest that there was some kind of
federal involvement here i mean
obviously we're going to find out
through the the oath keepers uh a court
case that's going to be happening very
soon if there was you know someone that
released information if someone gave
them something but again there's also
something that's odd about the timing of
the us government going after the oath
keepers all the way up until now almost
a year after this entire incident it it
raises a lot of question uh
it raises a lot of important questions
especially surrounding the pipe bomber
that also placed pipe bombs all
throughout washington dc the day before
there's a lot of different theories
about this to why this happened but that
story came and went extremely quickly no
one's talking about it that guy or girl
was never found and they were
responsible for setting up bombs all
over washington dc why isn't this a
bigger story especially in a
surveillance
state in washington dc that has security
cameras almost everywhere how does that
make sense and the remarkable thing is
is that it seems like the fbi does these
sort of fake gestures of you know
calling on the public to help them find
person in this sort of full-on
surveillance state as you point out it's
the same thing as like when they
initially called on the public to
identify epps it's clearly disingenuous
because the internet identified him and
they did nothing with it and similarly
in this pipe on case which is very
interesting for a number of reasons in
the python case they provide to the
public just very limited grainy
ridiculous video and we know for a fact
they have more video because there's the
video itself is not continuous we know
that there are more cameras in the area
we know that there's better resolution
stuff and so it's just not a genuine
effort on the part of the feds to
identify this person so i kind of wanted
to ask you and and i don't know if it's
fair to go off into the realm of
speculation but there's some people
assuming that the pipe bombs were placed
there in case the you know the people
wouldn't storm the capital and that was
used as another pretext uh that some
people are arguing and speculating that
of course we don't have any evidence but
but darren how would you speculate
everything unfolded in washington dc on
that day how do you think
things went down from your perspective
well that's an interesting question in
relation to pipe bomb in particular
there are a number of possible
explanations one is simply that the
bombs were there as certainly it's it
makes for a scary headline that you know
feeds into the
uh narrative that the media wants but
also it was a had a diversionary
function too is the capital already had
limited security personnel and when they
called in the you know the pipe bombs
the law enforcement actually
addressed the pipe bombs
basically contemporaneously
coincidentally enough with that first
breach that ray epps was involved in so
that's kind of
slightly i think it was about an hour
before the first breach of the barricade
the security went door to door to uh to
members of congress and told them leave
the building right which is
really
interesting right i mean it just yeah uh
we
i mean just think about it something
just so happened that before the breach
members of congress were able to be
evacuated from the building right
it's convenient it's actually i mean
it's kind of crazy to think that if it
wasn't for this person who put these
pipe bombs out aoc might have actually
been caught in in people storming the
capital of course she lied and
fabricated that whole story right and
i'll give you the simple context aoc
told this story on instagram where she
said there was a banging on her door of
her office and she went hid in the
bathroom and then thought to herself
they've got in and that she might die
but
that story about someone banging on her
door was the police sweep for the pipe
bomb which happened an hour before the
first breach right so you ac i'm not not
the first breach it happened around the
uh uh ten minutes before they crossed
the barricades but no one had to enter
any buildings right no one had had
breached the the stairs or anything
the crazy thing is you had people on the
left
advancing her claims and even people on
the right i got to an argument with a
guy from the huffington post when he
said i was wrong about my timeline so i
went through the timeline and i
responded to him and i said actually
aoc's story took place an hour before
the doors were breached why would she
think someone would go to her office an
hour before anyone had gotten anywhere
near the front doors and this huffington
post guy went oh yeah you're right good
point i'm like yes aoc fabricated the
claim the whole story some cop did knock
on her door and he said ma'am we're
evacuating the building
i still find it crazy that that bombs
were placed all throughout washington
d.c and our national security state that
has nsa agents literally caught doing
unspeakable things to themselves in a
pleasurable way to people's private
photos that they were not supposed to
have the nsa that knows almost every
little thing about you the the phone
that knows when you crap couldn't find
the person that that put bombs all
throughout washington do you see the day
before are you kidding me it's even more
peculiar when you think of all the other
reasons that they would have had to have
enhanced security on that day it would
be a scandal unto itself if the capitol
building had normal security but in fact
the capitol building had uniquely poor
security on a day that was sure to be
politically charged and requires uh
additional security and this is one of
many things
here's a pipe on but on january 5th
there was this so-called hippies for
trump van and this hippies for trump van
was stopped right outside of the
department of justice
with
explosives and firearms in it and in
fact one of the people was in the van
turned out to be one of the curious
characters caught on video methodically
cutting down fencing and barriers as
trump was still speaking and so the feds
knew who he was there was this terror
scare
right at the department of justice on
january 5th and even that didn't justify
or get people to say okay we actually
need enhanced security on the signal so
that's another very bizarre uh it's a
discrepancy there it's not just that
it's that trump was actually preparing a
massive rally right hundreds of
thousands of people that alone that
alone massive security precisely there's
a video where the guy at the capitol
goes to the cops and says what are you
doing get people down here stop this yep
i get the feeling that the the maybe
it's the news or whatever
isn't gonna really tell us about the
real threats because they don't want us
to panic so like the pipe bombs they
played that down if it was a real threat
but it's the stuff that they want you to
focus on that
tends to seem like it's not really a
threat like they want to get you wired
up and confused and angry about
something that can just be there but
like while they're secretly
investigating the real threats yep by
the way a cherry on top to this
originally the guy on video the fbi guy
dc field office guy
who did the public service announce
saying we announced to the public saying
we need your help identifying the pipe
bomber this was a guy called steven
d'antoino and his previous job was
running the detroit fbi field office
where he basically ran the infiltration
operation that's now known as the
michigan
kidnapping it was the same guy um so the
plot where there were more federal
undercover exactly
literally
12 out of the 26 people are either fbi
agents or fbi informants and this
happened just months before january 6
the same plot it's they called a
kidnapping plot but it was also a plot
to storm the michigan state capital it
involved one of the three
major militia groups impeded to 1 6 the
3 percenters it was fed infiltrated
uh with a percentage that you wouldn't
believe and the guy who ran it was
subsequently promoted to head the dc
field office where he went on to oversee
one six investigations what does that
say the guy that they indicted steven
d'antoino the the guy that they indicted
also had very serious mental health
problems oh yeah uh that wasn't a fact
in that industry yeah come on come on
come on guys let's just be real the
government wouldn't lie to us
our best interests there is no
circumstance in which a government would
ever stage something like this against
their own people that is absurd but uh i
did hear that russia is going to stage a
false flag against their own people
that's different they're russian they're
baptized and kissinger by the way is all
in on this yeah kinsinger buys it you
know completely i was joking by the way
for those that may have not bought into
that some people will be like is he
serious right now my point is you know
we can sit here and have an adult
conversation about things we want
answers to and you'll get smears in the
media that it's conspiracy theorizing to
simply question whether or not the
government could be lying to you well i
mean the gulf of tonkin is a example of
the government lying to you uh yeah they
lied to you they told you that
that their ship was fired on by
vietnamese war vessels or something and
it wasn't but
right now one of the big stories too and
i don't get too much into it is that
russia us intel russia is preparing to
false flag attack their own troops to
justify an invasion of ukraine and might
i tweeted this saying no false flags or
conspiracy theories no government would
attack their own people to justify an
invasion of any other country you can't
because false flags don't exist so you
can't do it right of course even though
historically most wars are started
through through force false flag that's
a good point
but now we're living in a magic fairy
tale land where where false flags don't
know it's just the us government that
doesn't do false flags
because we're benevolent the only people
who do false flags are iran russia and
china and maybe venezuela
it's funny because this conversation is
a conversation 10 years ago i'd be
having with a bunch of leftists like
anarcho you know antifa types right
where they'd be like the american empire
and the economic hitman in south america
and now they're the ones who are
basically like oh the government can't
be wrong well this thing it's it's new
for people on the right and that's one
of the hurdles psychologically as i've
said is the political psychology of the
right is largely that they want to
venerate
just and well-functioning institutions
of authority i think people on the left
like to challenge corrupt institutions
of authority and we're in a position now
where all the institutions of authority
are corrupt and
actuated against the right and people on
the right need to adjust their political
psychology in order to digest this new
reality the right is now the left and
the left is now the right in the in the
classical french revolution sense i was
talking about this yesterday that we
were talking to um
matt kibbe
you know in the french revolution the
right was the aristocracy maintain the
status quo and the left in the room were
the revolutionaries and that's what was
the big argument and that's where they
come from now left and right i don't
even know what they mean it means
economics it means cultural issues but
if we're talking in the classical sense
the right has become the counterculture
which was the left in the in the in the
classical sense and now you have the
quote unquote left supporting massive
pharmaceuticals supporting massive
multinational corporations and their
collusion with big government and i'm
like wasn't that always the right you
know like the the the big industrialists
and the revolving door policies where
they went and worked for government now
all of a sudden the right is critical of
this and the left supports it right well
there's a reason that you know one of
the journalists who've been most
supportive of our of our work at
revolver.news is
glenn greenwald yeah you know another
one is aaron aaron mate yeah he's great
so
you know it's because they've been
covering this for years and years and
this is nothing new like merrick garland
the current attorney general this isn't
his first rodeo he he cut his teeth
decades ago
under bill clinton where he was at the
doj under the domestic extremism
portfolio right at that period in the
90s when the u.s government was kicking
up its infiltration operation into
various militia groups and merrick
garland played a big role i think in
massaging the public's knowledge about
what happened in oklahoma city
so
um yeah this is nothing new a lot of the
same people they're getting the band
back together
and um
and you know some things just never
change i suppose except in this case the
target is has has changed to some degree
but
um
if if your listeners would be interested
i'd i would like to address this
seditious conspiracy charges i think a
lot of people
might want to know about that but no
definitely definitely we'll get into
that in a second i'm curious if uh if
you guys have a way for people to
contact you if they have tips or
information or anything they wanted to
share yes um
just email editor revolver dot news or
uh tips at revolver dot news uh we get a
lot so it's it's hard to look at
everything but we i really try to look
at everything because every now and then
you get a really good tip you know 90
maybe 9 90 of it is weird stuff like i
got one that uh the scaffold commander
who is one of the people featured in our
story of guys saying you know fill up
the capital fill up the capital he's
unidentified uncharged and everything
they're saying this guy is is uh bill
ayers
oh yeah we've got a lot of weird stuff
like that but
but every every now and then we get a
really good tip so it's really hard too
man and people you know people who are
listening to understand we i think we
have like 15 000 emails yeah that you
know that it's just not we we can't get
that number to go down right as much as
we go through as much as possible these
aren't like you know we we have we have
emails for support on the website which
we get to every single one of them right
and uh somehow sometimes you know look
for those that are listening gmail or or
your email service might it might get
booted into spam or something that we
try to go through as well but uh we get
through all those but then we go to like
tips and information and stuff we get
not only a lot of crazy stuff we get a
lot of stuff and it's really really hard
to to sift through and that that could
be bad because buried in there is that
golden nugget exactly it's hard yeah
you know i brought this up because
someone chatted that they they had um
meta fed
down there interesting who knows if it's
true or not i'm not trying to disparage
this individual who commented this but
maybe they never know you never know and
so that's that's part of the a real
journalist he's a conspiracy theorist
it's true um they they when they when
they come out in the media and say
you're a conspiracy theorist then
they're just trying to discredit the
fact you're doing real work because a
journalist should see something and then
say
i have questions about the government's
involvement in this and what their real
intentions are and then when the
government says we have done nothing and
you're a conspiracy theorist that is to
imply that because you don't blindly
trust whatever this person says i don't
care if they're with a government or a
corporation you must be wrong or crazy
there's there's two types of conspiracy
theorists there's the ones that can take
a conspiracy c theory and put it in
their mind and understand it and look at
it without believing it and then there's
the conspiracy theorist that sees it and
believes it without being able to
critically understand and think about it
and
you could say that they're both
concerned but we we're gonna have to
define a difference between those types
of people in that way of behavior
because i love taking a conspiracy
theory and bringing it down thinking
about it without believing that it's
real and just what if what if it's
awesome and that can lead us to great
places if you believe things when you
hear them you're you're in a very
dangerous place well let's talk about
the seditious conspiracy this is this is
the big play the democrats needed they
needed to be able to say that there were
sedition charges for their narrative
you've got the daily show now coming out
saying the no sedition you know uh
talking point is now officially dead
rest in peace in memoriam we have the
story from cnn oathkeeper's leader
appears in court on seditious conspiracy
charges but it wasn't just him it was 10
others so you want to break down for us
what this is about yes i'd like to say
some things about this first of all the
can seditious conspiracy charge is a
rare one and it's one that's even more
rarely used successfully if you look at
the history of it um there's only a
handful of cases the first couple cases
are weird like
cases involving puerto rico for whatever
reason then you have
uh one successful case against an
islamic terrorist and you have a couple
others that were not successful so this
is a very rare charge it's an extremely
serious charge
everyone else i believe on the
who is charged with seditious conspiracy
they already had
lesser charges the only person who has
just added completely
was the founder and leader of the oath
keeper stewart rhodes and i think
there's probably a lot of public
interest in
a reaction to this particularly because
my news outlet revolver.news has run
several
detailed investigative reports on roads
calling into question the seeming
protection that he enjoyed from the
federal government for not being
arrested and so forth and so i think a
lot of people are confused and some
people are probably erroneously
concluding oh he was hit with this
charge therefore
um he couldn't have been a fed and uh i
think
the there are a number of things to say
for that first of all i don't think any
of the questions raised in the
revolver's reporting
are dispelled by this i think they're
only intensified and here's some
interesting things about his case so
seditious conspiracy is a very serious
charge so we're we're supposed to
believe that the government's been
building this serious charge for an
entire year
and yet they didn't bother to search him
for an entire year
well asterisk to that they searched a
single cell phone on his person four
months
after january 6. so here's the founder
and leader of the most prosecuted
boogeyman militia group was all over the
media and he's so dangerous
that they wait four months give him four
months to destroy all evidence and take
a single cell phone from his person and
then wait an additional eight months of
zero search before they hit him with
this serious charge if they're taking
him seriously enough to hit him with
seditious conspiracy how do you explain
the fact
that they only took a single cell phone
four months after and contrast that with
an individual called thomas caldwell who
is one of his co-defendants now
caldwell
was arrested very early on in
mid-january
caldwell got the full
fed raid treatment where they went in
with guns they raided his place they
took every electronic in sight
then they charged him immediately with a
conspiracy charge to obstruct an
official proceeding
and if you look at the conspiracy
charging documents
the whole conspiracy of the government's
case is based on stuart rhodes's
statements and actions
and so that raises another question
about rhodes's seditious conspiracy
indictment why did the feds wait an
entire year
for this big indictment when they could
have taken him off the streets with a
lesser indictment either for the same
conspiracy charge that they hit thomas
caldwell for and others
or a trespassing charge
which we know he trespassed there's
footage of him
on the capitol grounds and they've
charged others with trespassing even who
didn't go into the capital so putting
these things together you have to wonder
okay they they were taking him so
seriously that they were building up
this mega seditious conspiracy case
through the course of a whole year and
yet in that year they only search a
single cell phone four months after
january 6 and they neglect the option to
hit him with a lesser charge and just do
a superseding indictment uh for the
seditious case so those are really
important questions that linger and i
think the seditious conspiracy charge is
actually a way for the government to get
away with the perfect crime and i'd love
to explain that but i'll i'll stop here
do you think that rhodes is a fed or in
some way involved with feds
i think that that is the most powerful
explanation for the questions that i
just raised when you guys say fed you
mean a federal agent not necessarily a
federal bureau of investigation
yeah fed is a
vague term i think that
the most likely explanation for the
questions that i raised was that he had
some relationship with some
government agency
is it is it possible that
the reason they didn't go after him
early on the reason they didn't try and
dredge up any other information was
because they knew there was none and the
only reason they're bringing charges now
is that it's an election year and it
justifies establishment political
talking points um i think that would be
a plausible explanation if none of the
other people were charged but if they
knew there was no information then how
did they get this guy thomas caldwell on
conspiracy where the whole conspiracy in
the charging documents
is full of stuart rhodes's statements
and actions
so if they thought that amounted to
nothing how do you explain that they hit
this minor figure who's just a fellow
traveler not even an oath keeper and
this guy who's built up as the big
boogie man head of the oath keepers they
leave him untouched and unsearched
here's my here you know i see all of the
uh
the the daily show did that thing where
it was like you know um
rest in peace the there was no sedition
charges talking point yeah i just
responded with has anybody been
convicted of insurrection or sedition
even well innocent
there's going to be no no conviction and
i here's what i want you to look i'll be
uh look
when a lot of people came out and said
was anybody charged with sedition or
insurrection we've brought that talking
point up as well and it's it's relevant
up until the government decides to do it
right so i'll say this right now maybe
someone will be convicted but the
talking point isn't that it'll ever
happen is for right now with a january 6
committee coming out and saying all of
these things right just because you
charge someone i don't care
when these people are convicted we can
have a conversation about right you know
that we found in a court of law they
they attempted to do these things and
that being said the federal government
when they charge people they have a very
very high conviction rate so is this
good except for seditious conspiracy
ironically except for so just two more
really important points about roads in
particular in this charge one is the
timing okay part of the timing was the
whole you know feds erection narrative
was at its absolute apex i think more
important than that though
is just
like a week before rhodes was charged
an attorney for another oath keeper
subpoenaed rhodes and was getting him to
testify
in the oath keeper's case and one
consequence of actually charging roads
is it clears him off the table so that
he has a perfect excuse not to testify
because he just pleased the fifth and
this is part of the playbook in fact it
happened in the michigan case one of the
big informants in that case was named
steve robson once he was outed
the government immediately slapped him
with an unrelated gun charge that clears
him off the table so that's one aspect
that i think is really important in
relation to the timing another thing is
this is if i were the feds
and i wanted to cover up the perfect
crime
i would do precisely what they just did
with the seditious conspiracy charge for
the following reasons think of what the
charge achieves one
it gives a big headline that for lower
information people or people don't
really understand the argument they say
oh he's hit with this charge he must not
be a fed so it quote unquote debunks the
right wing people who say oh fed
surrection
on the other hand it assuages and
satisfies all of these left-wing people
who have been furious that he hasn't
been charged for a year because in their
minds the government is protecting him
because the government's a bunch of
trump-loving nazis so it assuages them
but thirdly there's a problem if they
hit roads with a serious charge and
rhodes is a fed then rhodes has leverage
over them and could say i'm going to go
rogue if you guys betray me
but i think they have the perfect cover
story for that too because they could go
to roads and say look we're going to hit
you with a seditious conspiracy charge
it's going to sound serious but the
public story is you are going to
cooperate and get tell us what you know
about alex jones tell us what you know
about roger stone just smear a bunch of
dirt on trump's inner circle which is
what the media wants more than anything
and so the public story will look like
oh rhodes is cooperating because he's
giving up trump's inner circle and so
they won't follow through the charges
and so they don't
force
roads to go rogue they shut up the fed
surrection quote unquote conspiracy
theorists on the right they shut up the
people on the left who are furious he
wasn't charged and they put more dirt on
trump's inner circle
all in one move so i think i'm not
saying that's ex that's necessarily what
it is but if i were
consulting with the feds and saying
what's the most elegant solution to this
problem that you're in right now this
looks pretty close it would also shatter
the oath keepers i would imagine by
ripping the head off the snake well let
me just let me just point out
temporarily i need to point out one very
obvious and definitive fact
the the the federal officers here are
conspiracy theorists oh they they've
they've not proven any conspiracy
they've actually just theorized a
conspiracy took place and have yet to
prove it to anybody so for the time
being a bunch of conspiracy theorists
are seeding information to cnn who
reports it as fact mind you the reporter
i won't say her say her name is one of
the lead reporters in russia gate
i'm sorry i'm sorry i got that one wrong
that one wrong that was wrong not not
that reporter that was the the russia
thing but uh i'll just leave it at that
and i got that one mixed up
yes and just in in in light of this
conspiracy theory it you're absolutely
right and you're right in the literal
sense benny thompson who is the chair of
the january 6 committee in his personal
capacity
sued trump
roger stone
oath keepers and proud boys and laid out
his literal conspiracy theory which is
that trump's inner circle colluded with
the proud boys and oath keepers in order
to do january 6. that's actually the
conspiracy theory which is weird because
given the prominent role that stuart
rhodes played in the january 6th
chairman's theory he waited until
november to subpoena rhodes i find that
also a little bit weird and he only did
that after revolver news uh put on the
pressure by saying what the hell's going
on with the committee they're neglecting
roads and they're going after seemingly
anyone who was within a mile radius of
the capital on january 6 and taking
their phones and communications and so
forth so where does it go
well they're not going to convict them
i i think that's extremely unlikely and
i but i think a very interesting dynamic
is in play um a very interesting dynamic
is in play i think these are
um they're it's an elegant attempt but
it's also a risky attempt because the
the more that they do this just like
their cover up with epps saying oh epps
isn't a fed because ebbs talked to the
committee and told us he wasn't a fed
without releasing epson's exact
statements and without even telling us
that
uh epps's statement was under oath and
it's a weirdly precise statement of eps
not being a law enforcement official
well dod is not law enforcement there
are a lot of other agencies that aren't
law enforcement that he may have been
affiliated with energy i want to ask you
about this so
a lot of speculation a lot of theorizing
but to be fair there's nothing
definitive here when it comes to ray
epps no charges which is strange to me
to be completely honest because
kinzinger is downplaying the incitement
of insurrection and when it comes to the
oath keepers you bring up a lot of
interesting points as to why they're
only charging him now however
when i go to revolver.news
what's this newsguard says your fake
news good sir they give you a 0 out of
100 credibility score
now now why would that be are you are
you spinning spinning yarns here well
yeah so what you do to bill gates
right so newsguard is this sort of scam
organization that
basically their shill is they say we are
going to provide a nutrition label to
websites and
the websites that cover stuff about you
know uh covid that uh that the
pharmaceutical industries don't like the
stuff that covers stuff about national
security state that the various
authorities don't like those have bad
nutrition labels and so we reported on
them pretty strongly and pretty severely
and the organizations that are involved
so
just to give you a sense of what this
organization is like one of their
strategic advisors is michael hayden who
is the former head of the cia also
former head of the nsa whose claim to
fame was basically lying to congress
about the existence of the nsa
surveillance program which edward
snowden went on to reveal so michael
hayden's part of their group another guy
let me see his his uh uh funded by
microsoft exactly funded by another guy
is rick stangle he's a he's a real
champion he's also an advisor for them
he identified himself in a panel as
obama's chief propagandist and he stated
he has no problem whatsoever with
propaganda and in fact supports the idea
of countries using propaganda
domestically against their own citizens
and so this is uh rick stangle who is
advising newsguard to apply nutrition
labels to websites they have financial
ties to pharmaceutical giants like
pfizer and others simply put this is an
organization that's so compromised with
um with with such conflicts of interest
that the idea that not only are they so
the the arrogance and the hutzpah of
them saying we have the authority to
judge other sites but we are going to
ask other people to pay us to tell them
what sites they should look at and trust
it's really amazing and i guess it's you
know it's a good gift if you can get it
well i i
i don't think they're as bad as you put
them out to be but i do think they're
bad i've criticized them for being
heavily biased one of the things they do
is
you know these mainstream news
organizations are the basis for which
they decide things are true
so if you publish something they're
inherently biased against you to say
that's probably not true if the new york
times publishes it even if it's not true
it's inherently true right because the
only way they can actually fact check
something is by checking it against
mainstream news sources which creates a
feedback loop of mainstream media will
always be credible because they are
that's true but i think it's also quite
remarkable that they have you know deep
financial ties with pfizer and that on
their board is literally the head of the
nsa and the cia whose basic job it was
to lie if you're the head of the cia
your job is to lie but so here's the way
i see it and he's their advisor we we so
one of one of the sources we like to use
post millennial they're they're
certified as very credible um like you
know
very much so there are a lot of websites
uh daily mail probably shouldn't have
said that because they're gonna go to
their the site tomorrow and but most
millennials
have like one star the reason why
we we use newsguard is because we know
their bias and it's effectively a shield
so i love it when you know early on when
i started producing videos i'd get a lot
of these claims that i was pushing
conspiracies or fake news and so i
installed newsguard and now when we have
a segment up and we have the article on
the screen and it's got the newsguard
shield we'd say oh it's okay bill gates
approved us bill gates approved us
hayden approved us we only use sources
that are certified by newsguard so in
doing so first and i'll say this too i
don't think it's actually it's not even
that difficult to get certified by
newsguard it's just you need a
corrections policy you need to put
bylines in your articles and you know
let let them know who people the
economist doesn't have bylines
but what's newsguard's rating of the
economist actually you know the
rothschild connected economists who
don't have violence it's annoying
let's see if we can pull it up even well
they're good and they're they're
actually labeled as there are no bylines
on the economist
oh it's not usually i don't think so
some websites don't oh yeah look at this
no byline and newsguard says this
website adheres to all nine of their
standards including the site provides
the name of content creators along with
either contact or biographical
information well the first article i
pulled up doesn't have one let's pull up
another article and see if we got
australia cancels visa no byline
no bylines none whatsoever no byline
so this is what i've been saying about
their bias is it at the bottom of the
story by any chance is that possible
typically the byline is that it needs to
be at the top so when it says
international there's nothing there and
you scroll down and there's no buy lines
then surprise you to say there are no
buy lines on the economist good call out
by the way yep this is the issue i say
with their bias and it's
and it's obvious but there are many
outlets that you know they'll get a few
strikes but it allows us to to to break
through and effectively provides us a
shield and that can be like hey look
when this happened and it's reported by
this outlet and they say it's true well
it's certified by newsguard so good luck
the elite level is zero stars plus being
fired by biden that's that's how you
know
you're doing something right have you
guys heard this ipg media brands strikes
exclusive deal with newsguard to go
beyond website ratings to write
individual cable and broadcast tv news
shows well there you go this early
december 21. they're creating they're
they're trying they've been trying to
create at youtube and with newsguarding
with these other outlets an acceptable
lane of conversation
uh within reason i'm willing to accept
uh i'm willing to use websites that are
news guard certified when it comes to an
article you guys publish about like ray
apps and it's just it's showing videos
and asking questions about it that's
credible yeah you literally published a
video that's been published in other
places i have no i have no qualms of
that i can fact check what you put and
be like they're telling the truth
the fact that i don't know who published
it but i know you run it is immaterial
to me when it comes to project veritas
they give veritas a strike saying
they're not credible which is absurd to
me because veritas does original
reporting and publishes all of the
videos right so how could you argue
that's not correct well you're
absolutely right that i think largely it
is it is a kind of uh grift it's
basically the the theranose of content
moderation
but uh you know it's got all these
national security crooks um you know
advising but i think it's very
instructive so rick stangle the guy that
i mentioned who described himself as
obama's chief propagandist in uh we
revolver ran a piece exposing news guard
which may play into their uh less than
charitable rating of us but in in our
piece on newsguard rick stangle goes on
to say you know what as
it was a q a period and someone asked so
why aren't you going after fox news
what's the matter and he basically said
i'm paraphrasing but people are free to
go to the go to the article he basically
says you know i understand why you would
want to go after fox news but we have to
basically have this semblance of some
kind of neutrality and if we go after
fox news
it's just not going to work because fox
news is so mainstream
plus there are some good reporters at
fox like shepherd smith and chris
wallace
so he's like he uh those are the two
examples and shepard smith of course is
not there anymore and chris wallace is
not that
right so what is it a cnn an msnbc or
where something yeah uh i think he went
to nbc but i'm not i'm not sure but
that's the attitude they have and so
it's like well we kind of we can't ding
fox news completely otherwise we have
you know no pretense to credibility and
plus fox has some good people like
shepard smith you know that's that's the
attitude that they bring to this uh
content moderation assigning nutrition
labels which in itself is a bizarre and
somewhat creepy analogy to apply
information you know who's got balls
tucker carlson oh yes he because you
know i think he's better than uh um if
if i was gonna look at their prime time
lineup not the biggest fan of hannity
he's all right whatever i'm not the
biggest fan yeah laura ingram's pretty
good but not the biggest fan boring yeah
but and it's it's about originality it's
about
you know am i hearing something new
something unique and like
tucker right he's willing to be you know
make jokes he's willing to he he brings
up new information new questions he
covers things that i'm like wow he's
known for he's somebody like i i really
uh really am a fan of tucker and
uh friends with tucker and i've been you
know he's done you know uh a lot in
terms of you know helping um our
reporting and and so forth but i have to
say about tucker is you know what i
commend him for the most is he's in a
position
of tremendous power and tremendous
responsibility and he's one of the few
people that you can say he's actually
discharging that responsibility in the
right way not in the way that's easy but
in the way that's right and there are so
few people that in that position where
you have a cable show and millions and
millions of people are listening to you
and he actually
uses that position of authority in the
way that it should be used and um so i
think we have to give him a lot of
credit he doesn't just play party
politics exactly he's willing to
criticize the republicans he criticized
donald trump when donald trump committed
acts that were totally what he promised
not to do so he's going to go there he
has a tweet where he said something
about like the elites ripping off the
working class and dsa like democratic
socialists were posting it on their
forums like what bizarro world are we
win when are we in when tucker is
actually on our side on these issues i
bring him up because you look at shep
smith and you look at chris wallace and
they're the opposite they're the cowards
there there's there's no world in which
a sane rational person reading the news
looks at what tucker carlson does and
says
he's making this up because certainly he
gets things wrong but he's willing to
actually address factual issues that
people in the media are lying about and
touch things that no one there are so
many things that would not appear on
american cable television were it not
for a tucker absolutely across the
entire spectrum of cable news so what is
it at fox news that shep smith has to
flee from
bret bayer he does he's a fine it's it's
brett bear's fine he's just a straight
news guy so why is shep smith like oh i
can't be here cowardice they're scared
they want there's a cult phenomenon
happening where if you don't just toe
the line even fox news came out and i
will not drop this one on the on the
almond arbory case with mick michaels
cheered for the conviction of a guy who
was just filming cowardice if fox news
is unwilling to challenge something that
was clearly unjust because they're
spineless shep smith was still scared
enough that he'd leave right these
people are terrified yes and we were
sorry just we were talking about this
earlier
about cancel culture on the right and
and you were mentioning something the
fact that the right is actually more
willing to cancel absolutely people
further right of the moderate
conservative because they're too scared
to look like they're outside of the
opinion of the of mainstream you know
corporate press absolutely my favorite
moment on national television was a few
months ago when tucker carlson was
handing it off to sean hannity and they
got into an argument over jeff bezos yes
because
again tucker carlson wasn't afraid to
talk about the billionaire class and the
globalists that are of course are
connected to the cia doing horrible
things and hannity tried to correct him
on it and it made for just the perfect
television moment that was awesome to
see tucker was like we're being ripped
off by these guys and then hannity and
the handoff goes if someone provides a
service and makes money i got no problem
with that and tucker did the tucker face
where he's like you know old brow like
what right but so i i i you look at
these people who are now what you know
nbc or cnn
and what about
fox news's partial capitulation to
corporate mainstream narratives
scared them that they had to go full-on
capitulation of the corporate press
spinelessness
i i've been in the fox building i've
been on a bunch of these shows i've been
on tucker i think maybe once or twice
i've been on the prime time show very
often i went on jesse waters show
several times and i'm in the building
i'm in the makeup room i'm hearing what
these people are talking about these
people are questioning a lot of these
narratives they're in the fox building
for heaven's sake so how is it that shep
smith could be surrounded by
questions nuance and factual information
and go i gotta get out of here one
reason he knows it's right but he's a
spineless coward who's scared of being
ostracized so he jumps [ __ ] right and he
was tremendously unpopular with the fox
audience and probably got a better
contract at nbc
but i think there's a really important
point to be made about the um
the economy of media and you know the
the typical kind of
uh
metaphor use this sort of marketplace of
ideas simply doesn't apply to the media
because if it were the case tucker is
the most popular cable news channel
in the country and so you would think
just out of self-interest if it were all
just a business
people would copy him just to get his
ratings and get the
money that comes with it but that's just
simply not how things operate the profit
motive is not the core
of what a major media institution is
about influence always supersedes profit
and that's why you don't see everyone
lining up to just copy the tucker model
even on fox news because it's about
influence and it's also why you see
you know tucker
having you know advertisers cancel
it's why in my situation what would
seemingly be a a really great moment in
my career uh with revolver news where
i'm on tucker and tucker said wow you
guys did a great job here and the next
day were cancelled from google ads and
what other kind of business is it where
you maximize your influence and that can
measurably diminishes your earning
capacity it's so the the business of
information is just too important to the
system to be left to the profit motive
because it's the business of creating
people's reality it's a propaganda
industry that's why bezos bought the
washington post even though the
washington post doesn't make enough
money he doesn't care about that because
he's been ridiculous
exactly did you see the meme where it's
like the washington post writes an
article saying you know the problem of
the billionaires and elites then the
next one is jeff bezos purchases the
washington post and the next article is
we should cut some slack to the
billionaires in the united states
something like that let's talk about
this story we got from the hill
youtube temporarily suspends and
demonetizes dan bongino's channel this
is huge notably because dan bongino
plays a huge role in rumble i believe
he's one of their principal investors
and he's been moving off the platform
anyway not to mention his podcast the
the audio version is one of the biggest
in the world the hill says
youtube took action against conservative
commentator dan bongino's channel friday
suspending it for violating the
platform's covet 19 misinformation
policy and demonetizing it for at least
30 days
the week-long posting suspension stems
from a video where bongino said that
masks are useless in stopping the spread
of the disease youtube's covet 19 policy
specifically prohibits content denying
the effectiveness of wearing masks which
the vast majority of the scientific
community agrees reduces the risk of
infection this is true even the
frontline doctors have said to wear
masks this is one of the things that
really bothers me but dan bongino in my
opinion is entitled to his opinion
youtube doing this is driving a nail
into their own platform
and not only that
useless is it a fact statement or a
hyperbolic statement is he saying it's
not effective enough and just being
hyperbolic was his intention to say that
they do nothing or that they don't do
enough is the issue there's no room for
nuance when i see things like this it
says to me that youtube's actual intent
is just get rid of people like dan
bongino yeah people that are on their
way out anyway and they're like well
he's obviously sending his energy into
rumble right now and he's and he's
driving viewers from youtube too exactly
so they're like cut him off now but i do
want to point this out too for a lot of
people because we've had people on the
show uh question the effectiveness of
masks it is true on the box on the mask
box says it doesn't stop you know the
covet virus right but it does stop you
from spinning on people and and for some
reason there was this flipping where
early the pandemic conservatives wanted
to wear masks and then all of a sudden
didn't and now we're in this this era
where the right is saying you know
things like masks are useless let me
just say this i've looked at a bunch of
studies and a bunch of data the virus as
my understanding can be transmitted
aerosolized through vapor as well as
from spit if you're spinning if you're
wearing a mask you're blocking that spit
and i think it's fairly obvious that
would stop you from spinning on people
and help reduce the transmission of
covid the frontline coalition of doctors
that they do the mask protocol and talk
about alternative treatments actually
tell people to wear masks as well so i i
don't understand why there's like a
tribal thing to say not wear them that
being said i oppose the suspension i
oppose the censorship obviously but you
know what if it builds up rumble not
necessarily even the biggest fan of
rumble mind you but if it if it if it
breaks the youtube monopoly then so be
it let them be their own demise
i think youtube is also dealing with a
very tough situation rogan getting 40
million to 50 million views according to
some estimates with his latest
interviews with dr malone dr mccullough
and i think those big huge instances
that everyone's talking about is
something that of course youtube is
missing out on and that's why we even
talked about a few days ago why joe
rogan's move to spotify was a kind of
genius move a smarter move because
youtube could deal without having rogan
on their platform but spotify can't
youtube's already censoring you know the
videos that were on there but but there
comes a certain point where people start
seeing youtube for what it is and i
think youtube is reaching this kind of
pivotal point where they're like holy
crap everyone's kind of jumping ship
here what do we do i think this is a
kind of very important turning stone
moment where a lot of people are asking
the questions where do we go next
turning stone moment yes we need another
leukism
that's a good one yes i don't know what
a turning stone is but i do like the
sound of it we should make like a root a
stone with like you know ancient
carvings on it you know changing the
narrative the turning stone no i think
you know what we're seeing right now the
fear and panic over joe rogan and i i
believe what we're seeing here from
youtube is fear and panic over dan
bongino
so there have been a bunch of people we
were talking to the ceo of rumble who
was saying that people do live streams
on youtube and then tell everybody okay
the rest of the show will only be on
rumble so they simulcast at the same
time on both platforms and then halfway
through the show say bye bye youtube and
turn it off to drive everyone to the
other platform that's massive yes that's
that's very damaging dan bongino puts
his show on rumble suspending him will
do nothing in fact it will just hurt
youtube now my ultimate fear is
youtube plays a dirty game
they google alphabet they subsidize
youtube so it's very difficult for the
likes of say rumble to compete with a
partner program like youtube where
google gets all this money from external
sources and then pays people but as
super chats are becoming the principal
driver of revenue you look at salty
cracker who's on rumble and we were
talking to the ceo of rumble and he's
like this guy is getting insane amounts
of super chats he's doing better than he
would be on youtube because people
support him and they're involved and
you'll get a better community on these
other platforms i don't know if rumble
is the answer but you know what with the
more i see the censorship let these big
tech companies be their own demise it's
not yeah i wouldn't say the rumble is
the answer but it it's definitely a
soothing mechanism for the pain
for the moment it's not solving the
problem of tech censorship because it's
still a proprietary sensorable network
that is censoring actively it's just
more maybe more judicious in its
censorship currently
um i you know i'm all for it but we got
to free the software code the the
absurdity of the youtube position on
this as it pertains to covet
misinformation is that so much changes
every single day from even dr fauci
himself
how are we supposed to know what the
rules are or abide by rules when the
science keeps changing there's a meme of
faucius vader where he's like that
science has changed pray i don't change
it further you know the line you know
he's like the deal has changed or
whatever the arrangement so
when we're looking at their policy
uncovered misinformation and then you
get breaking news where it's like in new
york they have record-breaking cases
what are we supposed to say what how are
you even supposed to follow those rules
unless you are blind to history to even
recent history and you just repeat
whatever it is the mainstream media is
saying right you're going to get banned
whenever they feel like well
that's a great point because what you're
saying means that it's all about
controlling who's able to shape and
drive narratives
you can exist downstream from sanctioned
narratives and you're fine
but if if you're in the business of
shaping narratives then you're in
trouble because you can't get out ahead
of the mainstream authoritative sources
yeah it's as simple as that this is part
of what's leading to impact invest
impact investing have you followed this
impact investing sorry my headphones
just cut out and back in have you heard
of this at all impact investments this
is like 21st century people with big
money are coming to basically buy off
influence it's all about purchasing
influence now and getting ahead of it
well i mean influence is incredibly
important now you know arguably more
important than
money
and that's how it's treated influences
and you know the the media really is in
the business of creating people's
reality and that the the system needs
that to sustain itself the entire
ecology of how the ruling class exists
the regime exists it all rests on
shaping narratives for people and that
that's why it's more important than any
prophet and why profit motive is not
never going to be the ultimate factor in
any major media organization controlling
the myth do you remember when michael
brzezinski said that
i don't remember she said it's our
meeker business he said it's our job to
control what people think or something
like that yeah i understand there's this
shared community that's bigness
brzezinski's uh daughter by the way
who's also a very interconnected
globalist but the big aspect here is
that this was a temporary suspension
this is why i think this is an important
moment but youtube at first cutting don
bongino off and then coming back and
saying okay we'll give you your money
back i think they're in a desperate
situation i think they're losing a lot
of key critical viewers i think overall
people are realizing hey i don't want to
be dictated to i don't want an algorithm
curating what i should see i don't want
my perspective limited to a few tech
oligarchs and their flip flop wearing
yate latte drinking limousine liberal
viewpoints i don't want that i want the
internet that was first given to us that
was free that was open that was weird
that was wild i loved when i was able to
go on there and see raw humanity in
front of us and not a corporate disney
world viewpoint that is watered down to
save slogans and talking points and i
think youtube is is realizing that and i
think i mean
they're making a big change here and
that's why i think they brought back
monetization for bongino let's brought
back what do you mean
temporarily thirty no no he's kicked out
of the partner program he has to reapply
in one month he's done he's out but
let's play a fun game this is called
micah miko brzezinski whatever our job
to control people think followed by her
public statement after the fact let me
play the audio for you exactly and that
is that's exactly what i hear what you
meet just said is what i hear from all
the trump supporters that i talked to
who were trump voters
and are still trump supporters they go
yeah you guys are going crazy he's doing
what are you so surprised about he's
doing exactly what he said he's going to
do well and i think that
the dangerous you know edges here are
that he's trying to undermine the media
trying to make up his own facts and it
could be that while unemployment and
the the economy worsens he could have
undermined the messaging so much that he
can actually
control
exactly what people think and that is
the that is our job yeah if you look at
the
and that is our job she said and then
she tweets today i said it's the media
job to keep president trump from making
up his own facts not that it's our job
to control what people think yo she said
trump could make up you know he could
tell people exactly what to think but
that's our job yeah right and then she
tweets she didn't say it right that's
that you got to be a special kind of
stupid to fall for the media at this
point i'm sorry man
i just i just can't deal with these
people i think that uh when you talk
about a shared mythology humans need one
otherwise they fight so we had
christianity for religions develop
basically shared myth and now like news
media is kind of like a shared mythology
everyone can tune in and organize and
believe the same thing but
obviously when they're lying to you you
don't want that myth we got to find a
more stable
real myth but what what do we do in this
fractured information economy what's the
real
mythology of today their ratings are
down by ninety percent
i'm you know i'm gonna do i'm gonna have
some champagne
i'm gonna sit back we're gonna have a
good night's friday night we got news
earlier in the week that that msnbc and
cnn's ratings are down by 90 guess what
our ratings are going up that's right
your your viewership is going up so you
know what i don't care about these
people i love exposing them and showing
these these duplicitous
uh evil people are lying to you and
manipulating and i i long for a world
where people they assume personal
responsibility they work hard they
strive to be the best person they can be
and that's only only that only will be
possible when they're getting correct
information for which to build their
lives off of
yep
and there's even poll numbers showing
that americans trust the media on kovid
for an estimated uh ten percent of
americans ten percent of americans trust
the media when it comes to code just
that little yup amazing you gotta be
careful without she's at 31 i think even
if the media is being honest like if i
draw a six on the table and you're like
that's a nine and i'm like that's a six
darren and then we get into an argument
we're both right but we're
obviously not saying the same we're
seeing different things but we're both
right
so even if a media is is being honest
with you you're still going to have
people seeing different things
and
we got to figure out a way to
communicate a shared like understanding
of reality even when we're seeing it
differently you know what i think i
think i'm going to buy a bunch of cnn
schwag and memorabilia because it's
gonna be you know now that they're about
to they're collapsing and crumbling yeah
it's gonna become you know like once cnn
is gone people get like oh whoa i
remember that i see him in the air it's
gonna be like the uh buffalo nickel
that's right that's right it'll be like
it'll be it'll be five years from now
and i'll be like yo check this out i got
a cnn mug
crystal pepsi yeah
good
good you know what man we have a
decentralizing media environment there's
good things and there's bad things about
it with the the bad is that some people
you know go off in rabbit holes that can
happen but for the most part you end up
with um you know on youtube and now with
competition forming on rumble the
ability to get multiple voices of
differing opinions which gives you a
healthier diet when you go on one of
these platforms and this is why i think
it's bad that youtube is censoring
people because here's the benefit
you can go on youtube and look up
something about immigration you can find
videos from me kind of moderate you can
find videos from crowder more
conservative videos from jimmy dore
anti-establishment left and maybe even
you know the young turks establishment
left you get all of those different
views you get a healthier diet through
youtube youtube censorship is turning
them into everything wrong with cnn and
msnbc that all their hosts tell the
exact same line say the exact same thing
and do not give you a healthy
perspective
i like the fact that there's more
websites more channels more
personalities that people have less
centralized power in this because now
you can have people who watch this show
watch crowder and jimmy dore and be like
hey tim you were wrong about this jimmy
dore said this and crowder said this and
i can be like oh how oh wow good good
point
more voices better
right censorship that uh diminishing
return more voices better diminishing
return on that for sure you have too
many voices then it becomes incoherent
although as long as you can select the
way you view the voices maybe more
voices the better i don't understand how
youtube thinks that they could have a
future when they're trying to shove down
our throats this nasty crap that is cnn
that people don't even want to watch in
airports and hotel rooms i think that's
given up i mean their viewership is
going down dramatically as tim just
mentioned but and and this is this is
their strategy whenever you look up
something user related we get cnn
something that people overwhelmingly
don't like how can a business keep well
again again it gets to the point it's
not a business in the usual sense and
the fact that they are continuing this
trajectory of presumably hurting their
customer experience and so forth
indicates for one that that's they're
not their primary objective is to be
important because they don't really have
to they're subsidized by the most
powerful company in the world
essentially and secondly
it shows the more that they censor it
shows that they're actually betting on
all of these incipient alternatives to
be crushed in some fashion or another
and i think that's another thing that we
should really think about is that yes
you know rumble's growing and these
alternatives are growing
but there might be just an ultimate
bottleneck to a genuine alternative to
what youtube was supposed to be and when
something gets to be too influential and
too subversive
the regime will find ways to destroy it
that's true but they are losing it looks
like and you know we have we had this
funny article i don't think we'll get
into it in greater detail but joe rogan
mocks getter
saying i don't know how to get off he
complained the site artificially bloats
follower counts by including a person's
twitter following and he's right about
that i don't i like getter there's a lot
of users on it that's important but i do
think gab is substantially better in
that they run their own infrastructure
and they're actually challenging the
establishment becoming a real thorn well
it's just a different enterprise you
know they're gab is really doing a full
spectrum like they're taking very
seriously the idea of just build your
own ex and they're doing it with the
platform with the server with this
browser with the payment process they're
they're going full spectrum and they're
they're just playing a very different
game a much more difficult game i give
them tremendous credit for
you know andrew torba for his ambition
his persistence his boldness
um and you know i wish him all the best
in it but i really think if if you want
to be at on the main stage as a
communications platform you're
ultimately going to come up to that
bottleneck of the national security
state and of the regime
and they have many ways to uh to deal
with emerging threats like this they can
go after centralized services of any
kind so if you control the logins if you
control the passwords if you store any
data the cia can come take it at any
moment so you want to decentralize
services in that manner and they can
also take your code your source code and
force force you to shut up and do what
they want and if you're the only one
that has the code they basically lock it
in and they they make it do what they
want so you free the code out so that if
you get stuck at least the code's still
out there for people to wrap up more or
less
we argue about the free the code thing i
don't think it's a solution it's for me
it's a vulnerability for this for the
deep state to take a hold of your
company if that's the only place where
that code can is exists
i just don't if someone builds code the
code belongs like to them and they're
the cia it belongs to the cia
no if google builds it the cio yeah
controls it basically unfortunately take
a drink everyone ian said free the code
and it is another one we need a bingo
card yeah
along with what darren what you're
saying is that they will the government
does come when the organization gets big
enough and will start to control it from
the united states even look at parlor as
you know parlor
i i think it's fair to say is a joke
compared to
gab and it's a joke compared to
getter and even in that case when it
looked like oh it might be some type of
threat
january 6 completely destroyed it
yeah you know on top of i think probably
incompetence and and so forth but all it
served was oh there's a bunch of
chaturan parlor pertaining to this
insurrection event
now all of a sudden it is a vehicle for
threatening the national security state
and it's treated like a threat and that
gets back full circle back to the
lindell situation is that if you are a
genuine threat to the regime or in any
in any remote sense you become iran
let's go to super chats my friends if
you haven't already smash that like
button subscribe to the channel share
the show with your friends and if you
haven't already get those super chats in
we're going to read your comments all
right a lot of the first super chats was
everyone telling us our audio was bad
and people were like tim's
their conspiracy theory was that we
purposefully had the audio band to get a
bunch of free super chats it worked
all right
let's see we got
nerdgamer says just wanted to say it's
been a rough couple months for me from
my gf of five years cheating and some
other family issues but whenever i watch
the podcast i feel like i finally have
friends to talk to even if i can't
respond nerd gamer buddy thanks for
being our friend and hanging out and
watching that show it's because of
people like you were able to do this and
it's possible and uh you know what man
go for a walk
go to you know go to a bar pick up a
hobby i'm a ian and i would like playing
magic at the gathering go to a game shop
you'll make a ton of friends and that's
always really important and the best
thing is once you're in the shop you can
put on the podcast and get a whole bunch
of new friends to listen to our show and
it's great marketing i'm just kidding
yeah dude do right by you and we
appreciate your you know you hanging out
we appreciate the super chat yeah
dalamar says monday morning and over the
weekend withdraw everything from
minnesota bank and trust to make them
insolvent destroy that bank well
i don't know about all that all right
you guys do what you think is right but
i will tell you this if the goal of this
bank was not to generate negative press
and be involved in this then the
stupidest thing to do would be to
terminate a very high profile
individuals bank accounts and all of
them at the same time
and now here we are everyone talking
about it congratulations minnesota bank
and trust you've put yourself in the
spotlight
all right joe byrne says hey tim and
friends can you please do a favor from
one chicken fan to another there's a
breed of chicken known as show girls
they're fluffy white chickens with naked
necks and purple skin fans will love
them
that sounds very silly so
the the uh the black star chickens that
we have the girls are beautiful this is
when you breed a rhode island red with a
barred plymouth rock oh those are silly
looking little things that's it the
girls have like these black feathers
that glisten green and purple in the
light it's crazy but the boys they are
goofy looking
they've got like brown spiky feathers on
their heads that like they're all
mismatched and and off color and
and they're silly and funny and they
they make funny sounds the show girl's
incredible it looks like uh what's the
dog that looks like that pomeranian or
yeah
it looks like a poodle the haircut's
like a poodle
so interesting
all right ghost of recon says public
banking you mean you want your bank to
be run by politicians and have authority
codified and lost dude you literally
want communism in banking no i want bank
to be run by no one i mean maybe that's
what cryptocurrency is is
public banking i mean all the ledger's
public so maybe that's what that is
perhaps
glizzy water says trucker from last
night i just had one of those effing
stink bugs scare the ish out of me and
my truck he was hiding on the cap to my
drink ah that's the worst they're
they're annoying have you seen the stink
bugs around here because they're like
the dc area everywhere they're they call
them shield bugs they look little
shields
they're doofy and they're kind of funny
they just stink if you scare them
but i i we also have wasps out here and
so in the middle of the work day you
know when it's hot when it was hotter
out a wasp would somehow find its way in
now that's a problem for me and then i'm
fighting a wasp in my room like you've
got to stop that thing with the stink
bugs though they're just
they're just really dumb
and you know
you don't mind them you know they mind
their own business and one time i just i
finished a segment because i so i record
my segments if you guys watch him at
youtube.com uh timcastnews and timcast
i finished recording cause i recorded
all live and then i saw a stinkbug
clapping
i don't know what it was actually
awesome i don't know what it was
actually doing but it was just banging
his little hands together and i'm like
yeah they're they're doofy little things
and then i suck them up in the vacuum
and throw them outside they dance they
communicate with movement insects do
yeah clapping for them hung out with
bugs outside and you'll get real close
and just watch them and they'll dance
back and forth and do a jig and then
dance to the other side and do a jig i
was also an lsd that day
but it was dancing it was dancing maybe
you don't actually maybe you don't know
what you actually saw i've seen it on
multiple occasions i that that reminds
we had that segment where ian was like i
was on a roof and there was a wolf
spirit and it was like i accidentally
let it my soul and i was high i was high
that night that explains it but that was
thc that night that was crazy
all right let's see we got
trash panda says part of the reason
japan attacked pearl harbor was because
we froze their assets after they invaded
china mess with the one mess with the
money and get clapped is that what
happened i did not hear that yeah
exactly how's that not more public
knowledge whoa is this true mr
brightside says trump booed for saying
he wouldn't investigate hunter biden i
don't want to hurt a family there's a
new variant of tds causes blindness is
that true did trump really say that i
haven't seen it yet but i wouldn't be
surprised right yeah yep
samuel pyle says i live in north
carolina and i saw on the local news the
us army is doing training across two
dozen counties to prepare to fight
guerrilla freedom fighters the military
is not on the people's side my friend
this is fake news
it's actually true they're doing this
but this is operation robin sage which
has been going on since the 1970s it is
a standard training exercise for special
forces
i think they have retired green berets
to do it they've been doing it for 50
years it's it's not a new thing not new
yeah yeah yeah don't don't don't you
know the media is definitely trying to
uh to hype that up
all right let's see oh yeah yeah this is
a good one seth covington says please
someone show me the video of the girl
who was rubbing onions in her eyes you
remember that
i don't on january 6 as a woman it's a
weirdest thing i don't think me i'm i'm
not saying i know what it means but
she's like crying like you see her
rubbing onion on her eye and then
someone records her and she's crying
about something this is a weird video
bizarre
yeah but you don't know what that means
you know what i mean like it's certainly
weird i can confirm uh in 1941 when the
japanese invaded the indo-china the
french colony of indochina the u.s
freeze their assets cut off japan from
iron petroleum and tech yeah yeah and
cut them off with uh energy and i think
that's why they uh
they needed the oil for their navy yep
all right h music says
in a senate hearing this week the fbi
and doj were asked why epps was the
first person listed as main suspects on
the fbi website and then removed even
though he hasn't been charged
additionally i think it was was it ted
cruz when he said were there any fbi
agents or informants and they said i
can't answer that question right no that
i mean that's true that was first
reported at revolver that ray epps it
was it's not like they can't they can
say we don't know who he is he was
considered to be one of the 20 most
important people immediately after
january 6 that they wanted to identify
the internet identified him within days
and they did nothing until revolver ran
a report on his fellow oath keeper
stewart rhodes and the next day they
scrubbed him off their public database
and since this all of this blew up about
epps the only subsequent official
comment from any fbi agent as i
mentioned was the phoenix fbi people
said they had no idea who he was
so it's it's a very
it's it's a strange situation for sure
all right dusty says tim i live in
colorado i was going to work the
national western stock show this weekend
and chose not to because the state and
national government is going to find 5
000 per person for not wearing a mask
inside i do not comply well i'll just
tell y'all this frederick county which
is right next to us has a mask mandate
and um
in the in in frederick proper we got
hassled over masks and it was the
weirdest thing because like we didn't
walk into a building and just start
fighting with people like we walked into
a restaurant nobody was wearing any
masks except for like the staff members
and then they were like put this on and
i was like well nobody's wearing any
masks and they were like that's fine
they're eating i'm like oh we're here to
eat like
they they said no so we gotten it i was
just like dude i'm not gonna do it i'm
gonna leave because they wanted me to
put the mask on literally for five
seconds and then take it off that to me
is nonsense yeah but
we went out to uh uh outside of
frederick proper the city and in the
county no no issues none whatsoever
nobody was wearing masks nobody cared
the businesses didn't care and these
were big chain businesses yeah barnes
and noble big corporate stores they're
just like we ain't doing it and i was
like well i guess for some reason in the
downtown area where there's probably
government enforcement they're terrified
but in the outer you know rims of the
county people are like get out of here
dude the border with virginia is five
minutes and west virginia is ten minutes
and if people don't wan if you're told
to do something you don't want to do
they're gonna they're gonna go find the
same store on this side of the river in
a different state it's that easy we went
to a sushi place and they were like the
chair was five feet in front of us and
they said put the mask on and i was like
nobody in here is wearing any masks can
we just sit down and they said okay fine
but if you get up you gotta put the mask
on and they handed me a mask i said okay
and then some guy the counter yelled put
the mask on and i said we're gonna sit
down and they were like no put it on now
and i was like are you serious and they
all yell yes and i'm like i'm leaving i
bet they thought you were a fed that was
about to find them if they let you walk
in without your masks nobody was wearing
masks though but they probably made them
all wear one from the door to the table
that's the stupidest thing i've ever
heard so you know we're like a secret
shop
we drove only a few minutes because it
was a border county we're only a few
minutes from the edge of the county and
we got sushi no problem it was quite
delicious at the other restaurant it's
insane to me that they were like if you
want to walk five feet you better be
doing it wearing a mask because
everybody knows what covid floats in the
sky and at six feet and it's it's the
stupidest thing man look i understand if
they're like a private business wants
you to wear masks but i'll tell you this
the government mandating vaccines or
masks in my opinion is a violation of
our right to peaceably assemble the
supreme court she agrees with you i
believe no i don't think they've ruled
on this yet but there needs to be a
lawsuit over this so i don't know who
files it or how i do not live in an area
with this perhaps i could sue over
something like that but i wonder what
would happen if i got a group of 25
people that said we're going to be
organizing a black lives matter protest
in this public location that is open to
all members of the public and when they
say sorry you have to leave i'll say why
and when they say the government is
requiring that we we check everyone for
vaccination stance and say aha the
government can't deny our right to
peaceably assemble under one a and then
we sue and say
the government doesn't have the right
to bar your right to take away your
rights through pressuring private
organizations the supreme court's
actually ruled that so i'm wondering
when someone's going to file a 1a
argument of that our right to assemble
has been shut down by the government
forcing people to kick you out so look
it's quite simple
if burger king wants my business
but the employees there are like i'm
sorry man the government's making me do
it that's all i need here and that's
exactly what they've been saying i
called 20 25 or so restaurants and they
also almost all of them said the same
thing i'm sorry the government is making
us do this all right then that is the
government violating our first amendment
rights to peaceably assemble
somebody should sue him
all right dusty says i plan on going and
doing some journalism instead let me
know if you want my footage are you
talking about in dc for that protest
um i don't know i think we have to go
through it we're very it's very strict
with how we have to run things peop this
is one thing a lot of people need to
understand too when you're running a
business there's a lot of restrictions i
mean i'm sure you deal with this stuff
too i've had people they they assume
that if you have a company you can just
give someone money so i was arguing with
this leftist who was like when are you
know i challenge these leftists when
they're like when they criticize
reporting or they try and act like areas
are safe like conan o'brien went to
haiti and said it was beautiful and
great so when i see that and i'm
tweeting with somebody i'll be like i'll
tell you what
you go and cover this story for me and
i'll pick the location how does it sound
and they say yes so i challenge this guy
here's what we're going to do
legitimately i will cover your costs
everything and even pay you to go and
cover gang rivalries in chicago we
actually it would be great to see how um
how covet has affected these these more
dangerous areas of chicago and we'll
have you do it and it's not even about
look i think i i think this person won't
be able to pull it off but if they're
brave enough they're confident they
think it's safe that's exactly the kind
of person you want to go do the
reporting right they won't do it though
they always say no but i had one guy who
was like nope just give me the money so
i can go travel wherever i want and i
try explaining to him
you can't legally as a business just
give someone money for no reason they
don't seem to understand this they think
if you own the company you can just
write someone a check and hand it to
them i'm like you you can't
like you are opening yourself up for
audit because people try
it's crazy to me that it's people on the
left doing this as if they're the ones
complaining about loopholes where family
members will funnel money to family
members it's exactly why you can't do
that when we're hiring people we're
required to have like a breakdown of
like what the person's job is and why we
hired them and we've gone through all of
this stuff otherwise you open yourself
up to audit i wonder if many of these
young people on the left started a
business it would really change their
perspective on you know who to vote for
to be honest
all right all right
bernie ketzeroy says tim what about john
sullivan who was a blm agitator and also
was there at the capitol leading those
inside he was put on house arrest and
still free yeah what happened to that
guy he was a hell of a guy he's an
interesting case um he's also featured
in in the revol article he's he was a
sensation part of the narrative early on
and a lot of people on the right like to
point to him and say oh it was actually
antifa that was before we basically
changed the narrative to look at fed
versus antifa and i think in the case of
sullivan that's also consistent with fed
versus antifa and you know i'm
definitely not a fan of antifa i think
in some larger sense antifa is a
paramilitary force of the regime but
it's also
a law breaking organization and they
also have concerns about fed
infiltration and
john sullivan was actually if you look
at various antifa blogs and so forth the
antiva people basically banished him
because of their concerns that he was
actually a fed
so
i think the actual explanation is people
are saying oh he's antifa no he's not
antifa he's probably you know something
else and antifa itself had similar
concerns so
there you go yeah he yeah he was
i guess when it came to antifa he would
try and incite exactly and they were
like get him out of here what does he do
and his brother is like some you know
right-wing equivalent it's a very really
bizarre family that is connected to
intelligence and so forth
you know uh just to go completely off
the rails insane i was thinking how
funny it was that i saw this image of um
what is it a puffin there's like there's
there's little birds and there's uh
a fake bird that in iceland yeah
yeah they put a fake one up
and then the puffins come and land
thinking it's a real bird and so they're
not lonely and they'll hang out with the
decoy or whatever then there's also
decoy ducks where it attracts the duck
they see this they don't realize it's
not a real duck i'm like wouldn't it be
funny if aliens put decoy people here to
like coax us into doing things and we
can't tell the difference because it's
the technology beyond us and so you end
up with these really weird people you
can't understand that kind of just
appear and do weird things i'm not
saying it's true i'm saying it's off the
rails but it's fun to think about it
sure
omega says tim you owe me an apology you
said i was wrong about the left and
right and now you are using the same
point i brought up over a week ago
yes i owe you an apology i think i
remember your comment and um perhaps you
are correct and i just did not realize
the the classical left and right was
anti-establishment and you know
pro-establishment and the modern left
today is has been pro-establishment for
the entire trump administration
trump was the bull in the china shop and
i was like all right fine whatever i'll
take it i didn't vote for him in 2016.
and as i've stated the other day trump
is now a bull on fire trying to break
back in
just going crazy and enraged and uh um
that is not the establishment this is
when obama got into power it seemed like
they all the warmongers that had coaxed
bush over there were like yeah let's
keep it going so they don't care what
side yeah they're like everyone let's
move obama walked in and he's like now
that i'm uh president uh
i'm gonna change things and then they
were like no actually you're gonna blow
up kids and you went okay
and then he did i think it was like it
was a few a few days after he got in he
got his first inauguration he authorized
a drone strike killing a bunch of women
that was the day he became president
that's like what they said about trump
is like he strikes syria now all of a
sudden all the bad coverage suspends for
you know a second they say now he's
president they give noble peace prizes
to people like that too you you bow to
raytheon that's when you're president
yeah
twerk for raytheon i love how they gave
obama a peace prize for not doing
anything like just like what is this
man the the mask came off the emperor
has no clothes all that stuff the past
few years have really shown the
establishment the regime the cathedral
whatever to just be a barren wasteland
they have nothing to offer yeah and and
just be honest obama was talking a good
game he was talking about ending the
wars ending the surveillance state
holding people accountable you know
making sure we protect civil rights and
people's personal liberties and then he
did the complete opposite of that
riley says today my boss said we have to
wear masks again i said i will not wear
one in front of everyone he said he's
just relaying the message i guess i'm
fine yeah i love that a lot of people
have pointed out that their companies
come to them and say okay mask mandates
are back and they go no and the boss
goes all right whatever yeah like we
tried if they won't comply we can't shut
down sick of it i mean look how crazy
it's getting that was it in california
they're having coveted sick nurses in
seattle and seattle right now
well because they don't want to shut
down yeah they can't it's it's what mike
rowe said that the bombs were dropping
on london and eventually people just
came out of their basements like well
what are we supposed to do and they just
lived with it
all right what did that say joelin says
i planned to ask tim to host darren
beatty asap after work i turned on tim
caster irl and lord have mercy it's
there in beatty there you go tim would
you mind asking darren about the late
bill cooper and why he was assassinated
who was bill cooper and was he
assassinated behold a pale horse i don't
know oh did you guys ever hear about
behold the pale horse
what's a famous conspiracy book uh
william cooper was navy intelligence and
he had some very interesting theories um
his book was very fascinating to read
personally uh i read it before um and um
yeah there's a lot of crazy information
surrounding uh bill cooper interesting
is he going hard on 9 11 because he died
two months after that yes really yeah he
died november 01. well there's people
saying that he predicted uh 911 but
again there's a lot of different
theories out there
raymond g stanley jr says darren with a
mic drop on newsguard yeah pointing out
the economist doesn't have bylines yeah
real was a real smack
yeah i've i've actually emailed
newsguard numerous times just like
because there's certain points where i'm
like i'll use them because like i said
it's like a shield that's like hey man
don't get mad at me i'm using newsguard
certified sources even the guardian
backed up joe rogan's claim on
myocarditis and i think that's you know
that's you know how you can get through
those the manipulation but there have
been so many stories like uh one very
important one was that the that buzzfeed
wrote a fake story claiming two black
men uh got into a fight over the death
for a fried chicken sandwich
they claimed it was when the popeyes
chicken sandwich thing happened and
buzzfeed wrote an article saying that a
man shot another man over a fried
chicken sandwich and i and i reached out
to the editor-in-chief at the time and i
said not only is this story overtly
false
don't you think it's a little racist to
make up something like this and he was
like well i don't know seems fine to me
and i was like wow the heck so i emailed
newsguard and i'm like how is it that
project veritas puts out a video and you
say it's fake news and buzzfeed
literally writes verifiably fake news
you can fact check and you guys don't
care
and they give me no response
the story actually was a guy was at
popeyes and someone cut in line an
altercation broke out when he walked
outside i guess the other guy stabbed
him and ran they weren't fighting over a
chicken sandwich it was just an argument
that escalated
and so the dude like the cousin of the
guy who died came out and put up put a
video online saying stop pushing these
lies man my my family was not fighting
for fried chicken what the what the hell
man we're fighting for fried chicken we
are fighting for something much more
important which is someone cut in line i
bet popeye's paid for that story the
dude who uh uh who died wasn't even the
one who started the fight apparently
jesus like the uh like he s some guy
caught him in line he said yo man you
can't cut me in line so the other guy
just stabs him like street fights and so
i'm like how how brutal to be a regular
dude just trying to go to a a popeye's i
mean they got shrimp there too and then
to be besmirched by all these news
outlets because they wanted a racist
story and then these people at buzzfeed
have the nerd nerve to call us and other
people racist or alt-right whatever i
can't stand these scumbag
you know left elites who think they're
better than everyone and they say
they're the anti-racist and they do
stuff like that and i and the
editor-in-chief doesn't do anything
about it when you said that they backed
up rogan's claim on the myocarditis is
that youtube friendly talking content
you want to i mean i did a whole video
on it oh today you did the guardian
published a story that said a study
suggests myocarditis risk from vaccines
is greater than that of covet joe rogan
referenced that in his podcast josh zapp
said he was wrong they pulled up a
source that didn't confirm what joe said
and joe didn't have an answer for it
okay and i'll say this to joe
i got a keyboard right here in front of
me so not only does ian have his own
computer and luke but i actually can
pull up information that i'm familiar
with see joe doesn't have that he has
jamie right so often what'll happen is
joe will be like hey pull up that source
and then jamie might pull up whatever
the first source he finds and it's not
necessarily the one that joe was talking
about so joe went out came out later on
twitter and posted the guardian article
and a subsequent uh a study from oxford
backing up his his claim and i said this
is the problem with alternative facts
joe is not wrong when he says
this thing has happened because the
guardian reported it
josh was not wrong when he said actually
this is true because he had a source he
read as well this is the problem with
the ever-changing landscape of news
media that people will read something in
the news no like i read this i read this
from a credible source and you can read
the exact opposite thing a day later so
then people just fight with each other
and i don't know how you solve for that
problem to be honest
maybe maybe we all just have no choice
but to keep communicating ask bill gates
what the answers are and just believe
him to whatever and michael hayden
michael hayden has veto power
particularly michael hayden james
clapper too right george soros he knows
everything i'm not going to look at this
guy michael just tell me what color it
is
it's green
all right confirmed
all right where are we at let's uh let's
see we got some super chats we'll move
down
we'll see what we can get
lone wolf says question if i can smell a
fart through the mask does that mean the
mask is working i tried three still
smelled it
but um those are socrates uh like
questions but i will tell you no fart
drops hold on if you are wearing even a
thin piece of cloth on your butt and you
get the hershey squirts it will stop a
whole lot of it okay the drop that's
yeah of the droplets that's right
the droplets
it was a really funny story we're gonna
get growth but there's a really funny
story that's like a classic reddit post
where a guy
was like talking about how he was
running down the hall in the middle of
the night after eating taco bell or
something you get the point of the story
but it was like one of the all-time
posts on reddit
you know no do you want to share it no
but i think you understand where the
story's going yeah i ate too much taco
bell woke up in the middle of the night
and long story short the underwear
actually ripped oh my gosh
there we go that's what i was looking
for
oh my god welcome to the grossest part
of the show hey it's friday night we're
having a good time huh everybody after
hours holy crap that's the first i've
ever heard that ever happening to
someone all right
i'm impressed sir john says i would love
to hear a round table with the who's who
to brainstorm how an entity would keep
free speech and not draw excessive
lawsuits over all the things people will
be offended about you can't well you can
sue a ham sandwich doesn't mean you're
gonna win um section 230 protects them
twitter isn't is absolutely able to keep
people on the platform they just don't
want to because they're hypocrites and
they're
well look man this is the problem with
the right conservatives and libertarians
did not get jobs at these companies and
thus they were taken over by leftists
who do leftist things i did do a segment
did
on my my tim cass news channel talking
about how
low testosterone is likely the cause of
all of our problems and it's that there
was a study that came out from the new
york times talking about how women favor
banning hate speech and men
favor free speech
i think this is in line with the fact
that men are more likely to take risks
women are more likely to be risk averse
that being said with the decline in
testosterone and men becoming more
feminine and less masculine we're
getting an imbalance where there's too
much of a toxic feminine presence in
government and not enough of a strong
masculine presence balancing out i i
personally feel like you need a
matriarch and a patriarch you need a
good female like assessment of the risks
and so and to pull back and tell the guy
like that's crazy don't do that but then
you also need a guy who's gonna be like
no i'm gonna jump off this cliff with a
parachute we're gonna make it happen
that is not to say that all women hate
risk and all men like risk it's just
generalities but when you get an
overwhelmingly feminist system because
men are becoming weaker and weaker with
low testosterone then it stands to
reason you're going to get banning of
hate speech you're going to get
authoritarianism you're going to get all
of these things i think jordan peterson
talks about this too
like the long house the long house what
is that basically just uh
the
matriarchy of these
matriarch societies that had these long
houses where the women would basically
just
dictate all conversation and every
everything's mediated through the social
reality and it's not it's truth value
not its connection with first order
reality it's the social reality
determines everything and social harmony
determines everything and therefore
conformity and consensus uh are
dispositive that's interesting hunter
gatherers where the men would go hunt it
was not about what they thought reality
was it was the bull is charging right
run and the women would be at home
talking about the men and how they want
things to be and then so i think that
aspect has taken over our society as
we're more talking about it rather than
dealing with what's really happening
well yeah there's an interesting thing
they mention is that
more masculine societies tend to be more
warlike there's a pacifying effect to
having more women involved in government
but there's an imbalance when you have
the right amount of men and women you
get less war and and
more stability but still a balance of
people's freedoms and rights but when it
becomes more feminine this actually
occur occurs in a lot of revolutions
that turn towards towards the left
you end up with internal conflict
authoritarianism which just makes the
quality of life go down like china which
are one child policy that has
overwhelmingly too many males so
interestingly i was reading about the
bolshevik revolution women were kept out
because they were considered to be very
conservative because they did not want
to be a part of the revolution they said
we want to be safe
there's no point in striking or
protesting it's too risky for our
families and it wasn't until the food
stores were getting depleted that women
actually came out and protested
similarly with the french revolution so
you you see there's an internal conflict
when you know there's an imbalance but
to be fair a lack of food causes
imbalance i don't think it's necessarily
anything to do with men or women
i just think right now what's happening
is we've we've known this for decades
testosterone is going down men are like
masculinity's on the decline it's also
being demonized and then we're getting
the rise of authoritarianism and i think
that makes sense we need a good healthy
and it is a
feminine type of authoritarianism it's
right and i think it because it gets to
the point that we're talking about the
distinction between first order reality
and reality is perceived through the
social system we're talking about the
function of media and we're in the
basically a media run state in in in
certain ways the media creating that
reality is fundamentally a kind of um
feminine mechanism that everything's
filtered through this kind of
manipulative social control rather than
uh just kind of
interacting directly with reality and
seeing what reality reports back
all right
stachowski says tim it's funny you
talked about cia taking over watching
big companies some people would say you
follow under that guideline who's your
cia agent
very funny guys there is no cia agent um
but let me tell you something for real
let's be real
we're no longer in the era where there
needs to be a handler for the manipulate
manipulation of media if youtube
decides that we do the right kind of
media they'll prop us up
what you need to understand about how
media manipulation works and has
probably always worked
these companies in new york don't
take a journalist and then say we want
you to report propaganda from the left
they find people who are overtly leftist
activists and then say want to be a
journalist
bring them in and say write whatever you
want yep that's what they do impact so
if you think this show is you know like
we're cia agents haha it could actually
just be that we do the kind of show that
they want us to do and so that's why
we're not getting banned that's why
we're on youtube that's why we're
getting views
because they've just decided behind the
scenes we don't need to have condo with
them i pointed this out before too can't
remember who we had on the show and i
was just like i don't know what's going
on but they certainly tolerate what i do
because we're making a lot of money
we're growing and expanding so i don't
know what it is the goal of google and
the establishment is maybe they're not
as powerful as we think or
they like what we're doing for summer i
looked on twitter and i saw your
trending
under entertainment i know not under
politics yep and it's been and i've been
trending for that's good on and off for
like two months non-stop to me that's a
win from joining tim cast the tim cast
organization oh sorry my my audio is
going cutting it out to see us trending
as an entertainer to see you trending as
an entertainment icon instead of uh
politics icon is key because the cia
they go after the politics people if
they're gonna go after anybody the
entertainers are here to put to calm
people down what i was told um by some
people who work at google is that
there's a lot of people who are actually
fans of the show who work there
and so they actually play some kind of
um speed bump to the overt far left
attempts at coming at the show i think
the same with the cia too i bet there's
a lot of people there that are super
cool and like this is crazy this world
we need a better system but but it only
is only defensible insofar as you're not
overtly publicly demonized so there's
probably a lot of people at youtube who
are fans of crowder but it's becoming
increasingly hard for them to speak up
in his defense because the media attacks
and attacks and attacks same thing with
alex jones so it's only a matter of time
for us in my opinion especially in 2022
with an election year but anyway it's
friday night my friends we got a lot of
work to do and a lot of fun to be had
i'm gonna go crack some champagne and
celebrate the decline of cnn's ratings
so make sure you subscribe to this
channel smash that like button follow us
on instagram at tim cast irl you can
follow me at timcast darren you want to
shout anything out yeah follow me at
revolver.news to see all this reporting
read it and share it with people to
challenge them what do you think about
january 6 and follow me on twitter at
darrenjbeedy d-a-r-r-e-n-j
daryn thank you so much for coming
shouts out to everyone in the comment
section that's calling me bluk yes
apparently there was a white balance
issue with my camera
and no i did not take the jab anyway uh
if you're bored this weekend check out
lukeuncensored.com we have three master
classes on survival journalism travel
hacking all available to you uh i think
we have over hundreds of videos all
available to you lukencensor.com
thank you so much for having me and
today was really fun appreciate you guys
love you guys thank you so much for
coming and check out my website ian
crossland.net it'll portal you over to
my social media accounts and i'll see
you next time
i'm really enjoying bluk myself and i do
think that cracking a bottle of trump
champagne is probably the single best
possible way to celebrate cnn going down
the tubes and you guys might you guys
may follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlitz i just want to point this
out too we when we were over the
holidays i was hanging out with friends
and family we actually had trump wine
and trump champagne and we thought it
was funny and so we bring the trump wine
to a family gathering and everyone has a
laugh they're like i trump wine and it
was they loved it they the whole bottle
was gone in few minutes so then we
cracked open trump champagne you know
when we came back we brought some with
us
it was delicious i'm not a big drinker
and then we got another bottle of
champagne didn't like it i was like wow
like i actually like the trump champagne
i hear good things but i'll leave it
there with that being said that free
that free shout out for trump champagne
thanks for hanging out everybody friday
night hope you enjoy the weekend we will
see you all we're going to be putting up
on sunday the sunday uncensored episode
so you can listen to those on itunes and
spotify but don't forget we got a
massive library of uncensored content at
timcast.com thanks for hanging out we'll
see you all next time
you